non non mais c'est après si tu veux il y
aura 50 balles tu me dois 50 balles
c'est dire que si tu pe retir à l'arc il
y auras 100 balles est-ce que tu es fort
retir à l'arc merci tu tu ne veux pas tu
ne veux pas en parler tu verras tout à
l'heure
alors oh tu descendre déjà de 5 ou c'est
qu'un jeu he ah non mais c'est bon donc
tu es chaud sur le tirarc estce que tu
es bon tir àaris pas mal tu es pas mal
c'est-à-dire sur une échelle de 1 à 10
12 c'est bien vous avez pas été prof
vous de tir à l'arc j'ai pas non pas du
tout jamais été prof de dans
ê mal non pas non pas du al c'est pas
moi qui choisi l'épreuve franchement je
vous jure que c'est pas moi qui choisi
l'épreuve ils ont trouvé ce qu' avait
donc je vous dire ça fait as déjà gagné
un concours tir non non ça fait très
longtemps que j'ai pas tir 3 semaines
vous vouliz représenter la Tunisie aux
Jeux Olympiques
[Applaudissements]
aur une chèvre tir je une chèvre tir à
non mais sans rigoler tout de suite non
mais on va quand même essayer
je vous dis ça fait très longtemps que
j'ai pas tiré un arc voilà mais je vais
essayer de le faire par contre on n pas
le truc là parce que ça pebondir ici
faut mettre un truc normalement ah ouais
quand même matériel de quand même non je
demande parce que j'ai vu des gars je
regarde beaucoup les jeux Olympi bien
sûr Sébastien Flut Sébastien Flut
exactement c'est un grand tireur et
ouais Sébastien Flut vous connaissez
Sébastien FL bien sûr voilà il y a que
qui connait Sébastien Flut parce que
c'est il a de la f Il en fais
beaucoup allez onolen explique après
j'ai expliqué à Moar comment perdre 100
balles aussi rapidement possible tu te
sens bien très bien I Love You tout
c'est avec nous c'est Go
[Applaudissements]
explique merci merci d'être là che
Go alors est-ce que vous avez révisé
déjà le cours sur le
493ors
sou les petits fil bustiers là surprise
j'adore il y a 3 semaines ça fait 3
semaines que semaines donc c'est le
complément comme comme on l'avait vu
pourquoi c'est le complément parce que
vous souvenez peut-être de l'article 3
de la Constitution qui dit quoi la
souveraineté nationale appartient au
peuple peuple exerce par ses droit droit
oui c'est droit c'est représentants
c'est-à-dire les les membres du
Parlement et par le
référendumendum donc vous voyez on a vu
que quand les représentants c'estd les
élus de l'Assemblée nationale et du
Sénat étaient privés de et de vote
c'était le 493 donc c'était une atteinte
en quelque sorte à l'esprit de l'article
3 et donc l'autre respiration
démocratique très importante c'est le
référendum le référendum on peut pas le
faire sur n'importe quel sujet non donc
il est possible sur l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics on y reviendra tout à
l'heure parce que je vais vous
interroger sur un certain nombre de
référendum qui on a de tris qui pr moins
les malins oh là là par exemple la
réforme du Sénat durée du mandat
présidentiel et cetera ensuite le
deuxème c'est c'est la politique
économique et sociale par exemple il y a
une tentative de référendum récemment
sur la réforme
des parfaitement et troisièmement les
traités les traités internationaux les
traités internationaux bravo pas mal
bravo marqué
derrière c'est marqué
derrière madame madame c'est marqué
derrièrere et que dit également ce texte
que disent également le texte c'est
qu'il faut une question
de la loyauté et de la clarté pourquoi
est-ce que c'est écrit cela c'est pour
éviter les référendum plébicite on
pourrait poser n'importe question
voulez-vous qu'il fasse du soleil ou
qu'il pleuve voulez-vous et cetera on
pourrait avoir très bien un chef de
l'État qui poserait n'importe quoi comme
question au référendum qui aurait un oui
massif et qui dirait bah vous voyez tous
les Français sont d'accord avec ce que
je fais ou et cetera donc voyez c'est
très encadré pour que le référendum soit
à la fois sérieux et qu'il a un sens
équilibré depuis la Constitution
c'estàdire depuis 1958 combien y a-t-il
eu de référendum neuf neuf parce que
c'est écrit non non non ah non mais très
bien bravo guigi bravoors on va pas les
afficher tout de suite les les parce que
je suis sûr que vous vous les connaissez
alors j'en ai pris quelques-uns j'en ai
pris cinq il y en a il y en a eu un sur
j'ai vous demandé les résultats de
allez-y il y en a eu un le premier qui a
marqué l'histoire de France c'est
l'élection du Président de la République
au suffffrage universel direct alors
mettez pas les réponses est-ce que les
Français on dit OUI ou on dit non alors
à votre avis
ou qui était qui était le président de
la République à ce momentlà Patrick
Fiori général de Gaulle voilà le général
de Gaulle ensuite il la réforme du Sénat
pas la rép faite également en 1969 par
le général de Gaulle il voulait voilà la
réponse a été non qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé après il est exactement il est
parti c'est-à-dire qu'il a tenu compte
du vote populaire des Français qui très
très courageux parce qu'il y a d'autres
qui ont perdu des référendum qui ne sont
pas partis et il a quitté le le pouvoir
considérant que les Français finalement
avaient
son ensuite référendum vous en souvenez
peut-être vous êtes très très jeune mais
peut-être que certains d'entre vous
votai déjà le traité de Maastrich bien
sû oui donc le qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
au traité de maastrichoui très c'était
très très serré il y a eu 51 % on voit
déjà que les Français sont très
exigeants à l'égard de ce que l'Europe
peut faire ou ne pas faireétait
président en l'an 2000 il y a eu la
réduction du mandat présidentiel de
combien à
combien 7 à 5 ans quelle a été la
réponse oui ou oui oui et enfin en 2005
d'ailleurs moi si je peux me permettre
c'est
je trouve que c'est une connerie ah oui
pas
temp vrai
voilen je préfère un
tuis
Renou vra un débat qui revient
régulièrement sur sur la durée du M on
pour le faire et le dernier c'est la le
référendum sur la Constitution
européenne quelle a été la réponse la
réponse a été non et pourtant
ultérieurement ENF je vais pas rentrer
dans le détail mais il a elle a été
quand même imposée aux Français ce qui
ce qui ce qui a créé aussi un espèce de
de de de doute et de discrédit à l'égard
de l'utilisation d'un outil
constitutionnel aussi important que
celui-ci et alors en 2008 qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé en 2008 puisque tous les
candidats à l'élection présidentiell don
je plus vra ont tous promis de créer un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
c'est-à-dire que voilà que les que les
Français puissent en faisant des
pétitions soumettre au vote des réformes
des décisions des du progrès social et
cetera et donc en 2008 il y a eu cette
réforme qui devait s'appeler donc le
référendum d'initiative populaire et il
y a eu tellement de conditions
draconiennes qui ont été mises à ce
référendum que finalement il n'a jamais
pu être organisé et déjà dès le début il
y a une grande méfiance de de ceux qui
qui gouvernaient à l'égard de de ce
pouvoir populaire finalement parce que
le mot populaire a même été éliminé au
profit du mot partager voyez ça
référendum d'initiative populaire alors
que voyez la souveraineté nationale la
souveraineté populaire elle est dans la
Constitution mais ils ont même eu peur
du mot populaire ça s'est transformé en
mot partagé et c'était même pas le mot
citoyen vous vous souvenez peut-être
pe-êre que dans la réforme des gilets
jaunes il il y avait des revendications
sur le pouvoir d'achat une lutte contre
la hausse du prix de l'essence avec la
taxe carbone et une revendication très
forte du référendum d'initiative
citoyenne du RIC parce que justement les
Français estimaient que s'ils avaient
s'ils avaient donné le leur opinion B
peut-être que les décisions seraient un
peu plus intelligentes que que quand
elles sont imposées d'en haut donc
pourquoi est-ce que ce référendum
d'initiative populaire a été tellement
encadré d'abord parce que il faut qu'il
soit signé par 20 % des membres du
Parlement ensuite signé par 10 % des
électeurs inscrit ça fait combien 10%
des électeurs inscrits ça fait à peu
près ah 500
maisli
4800000 près de 5 millions d'électeurs
et puis des délais qui sont très longs
très contraignants et cetera et donc ce
qu'on avait ce qui avait été voulu en
terme de démocratie participative et
prier français en terme de démocratie
participative finalement n'a pas été
réalisé V comment c'est intéressant je
vous jure que c'est vrai franchement on
se régale je jure que c'est vrai ah oui
on apprend bah on apprend bah oui bah ça
vous change de d'habitude oui vous
voulez vous avez des questions pour
l'instant ça en fait tout est fait pour
qu'il a jamais de référendum c'estgolen
faut être clair mais c'est Madame c'est
Madame c'estgolen Madame Royale alors
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que
régulièrement il y a il y a une réforme
de cette procédure qui est proposée
espérons qu'elle viendra espérons
espérons qu'elle viendra parce que vous
voyez même vous vous souvenez pour le
pour les la réforme des retraites il y a
une tentative de référendum ouais c'est
vrai et tout avait été réuni puisque il
y avait il y avait bien les 20 % de
signature des membres du Parlement il y
avait eu le lancement de la pétition al
a obtenu facilement 5 millions de de
signature et c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel qui a arrêté la
procédure en disant mais non la loi est
pas encore voté donc il ne peut pas y
avoir de référendum sur une loi qui
n'est pas encore votée alors qu'elle
allait l'être dans quelques jours après
en étant imposé par le 493 c'est-à-
direire on a eu un conflit de deux
formes de démocratie finalement
d'exigence démocratique contre un
étouffement de la démocratie puisque
d'un côté il y avait une revendication
de plus de 5 millions de français pour
faire un référendum et de l'autre côté
le Conseil constitutionnel qui a dû
appliquer strictement parce que j'vez
pas le choix strictement l'encadrement
qui était prévu dans les textes de la
pour la pour la même si le le le ceux
qui ont fait la réforme de la
Constitution et le référendum n'avait
pas imaginé qu'une loi aussi importante
que les que celle des retraites allitre
imposée par le 493 et qu'on interdirait
un référendum sur une loi qui soi-disant
n'était pas encore adoptée alors qu'on
savait pertinemment qu'elle allait
l'être donc vous voyez qu'il y a un
espace de de réforme institutionnelle et
peut-être pour conclure vous avez vu que
dans l'actualité oui aujourd'hui on
annonce des réformes euh de un
dispositif Antime j'ai vu j'ai vu j'ai
vu mais à votre avis quelle est la
meilleure solution pour qu'il n'y ait
pas d'émeutes qu'il n'y ait pas d'meut
référendum pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'émeutes pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
révolte sociale quelle est la meilleure
solution pas d'meut faut pas la chass
pour qu'il ait pas
d'émeutes bon je de mot mais pour qu'il
y ait pas d'émeut faut pas qu'il ait de
révolte sociale pour qu'il y ait pas de
révolte sociale il faut faire des
réformes intelligentes discuter avec les
gens discuter avec le peuple acceptter
par le peuple voir adopté par référendum
VO adopté par une majorité de de
parlementair mais pas imposé par le 493
pas de
provocation ou alors avoir la capacité
de reculer donc voyez quand on est dans
un discours uniquement répressif c'est
aujourd'hui on va mettre des sanctions
supplémentaires sur les jeunes et cetera
mais les jeunes feraient pas les
imbéciles dans à la fin des
manifestations s'il y avait pas de
révolte sociale donc la question de la
prévention de la révolte sociale par le
fait de bien dirig de bien décider et
d'associer le peuple aux décisions qui
le concerne c'est quelque chose de
majeur qui est inscrit donc dans
l'article 3 de la Constitution donc
[Musique]
appliquonsle